okay so like I said my name is Michael
Caine today I'm going to be talking
about I'm actually gonna be talking
about a communication framework that
word around for a while I'll fix it and
distributed data structures essentially
they're on top of on top of the
communication whatever they're talking
about um so since this is kind of a
smaller or I mean not i mean i'm not a
microphone or anything oh and i'm not
really into like into waiting to be a
impulse control so people have questions
you can ask them immediately just yell
them out and you know i'll try to answer
them um if you're a mucker anger you
know go right ahead please I thinking I
think it makes for much better talk so
first a word from my sponsors so um so
first just isn't enough acknowledgement
some of the work that i'm going to show
was actually done by Sir Simon advantage
who was part of the arc or is that a new
labs research you know that was actually
to do get some
I needed some in asynchronous
functionality in our I'll talk about
that a little bit and I was clearly
identified assessment that heated the
other thing is hardest part of the rate
the research that's being presented it
is part of the accident program which is
part of the the White House is Big Data
initiative there's this point one also
all right so to begin with oh so one
other things um I wanted to just as a
whole are I'm quarter power programmers
here all right is it mostly Python
programmers started some high program in
java programs all right some more java
programmers all right so that the Duke
crowd has come to beat me up maybe
alright so the almost nothing that i'm
going to present here is really are
specific it's more the design i'll show
a little bit of our mode but it's pretty
straightforward if somebody has a
question on that again please don't
um so I'm going to start with that's
deconstructing distributed computing so
I want just to start I want to just
think about what's what are kind of the
essential elements for for doing this
tribute computing and so I'm going to
have somebody is a little bit different
nomenclature I'm use coordinator for if
you're from the MPI problems will be a
master but I say coordinator because I
wanted to meet on something a little bit
different and in the workers so what
usually happens is you have and this is
for inter about dynamic languages or
interpreted languages usually you start
out with a set of expressions on
coordinator so the coordinator is going
to be is going to be the process that
creates these expressions that should be
executed out in the cluster after that
the expressions are moved to parallel
processes they're evaluated and
sometimes the results of those
evaluations need to be moved around
between the workers so I'm not just
thinking about the about embarrassingly
parallel
I really want to think about top of
distributed computing full generality
data can be moving all around the
cluster and then to move enemy and then
they go back to the coordinator usually
and it's some results returnable so in
terms of essential components you know
we have the coordinator that describes
the computation that supposed to happen
about on the cluster the worker is that
about you the expressions need some
mechanism for giving the data from the
coordinator to the workers need some
other mechanism mechanism that gets data
between fingers and then some other
mechanism and gets a result back to the
coordinator so we're really talking
about a distributed communication
protocols the actual evaluation Rose is
pretty simple one you know whether your
icon job over our you're really just
getting expression in your calling eval
so in terms of the existing
communicative of protocols the big one
has been traditionally nokia right so if
you have some of the model for MP is you
essentially define all of the data
movement upfront and then the workers
workers end up communicating directly or
tend to communicate directly through
other through these things called mayor
of mailboxes I don't think of MP is the
performance is really good it's it's
probably yep and I most yep it stick
itself if you compare it to most the
other mr. just really computing
platforms it's it's it's performance is
is usually the best the problem is it's
not very fault tolerant the reason is
because you are describing all the all
of the data movement up from if one of
the machines goes down in the middle of
the computation then you have this
problem where the that description is no
longer valid for the computation that
you want to bet you want to
um so I've mostly seen this in our the
other way that we can do that we can do
distributed computing and again I think
it's I don't know what a lot of cases
were so I've only seen recently i
haven't seen really much older cases but
i'm using a configuration service so in
particular i like rats so Redis is a key
naughty database and I have an example
barcode basically you have you have a
coordinator coordinator once because you
can do a push on to brett has this
notion of lists they can also act as
cues so I can do a push pull pull of
work recession and then I can turn
around and say into a blocking pop on a
different different list called the
coordinator view now this will actually
block until we have something back so I
can give it come yet so so this so this
won't happen until some until somebody
somebody put something in the court
neighbor cube which is exactly what show
here with this we're doing rut is
connect we're popping something that was
pushed we see it hello work recession
and then I'm going to I'm going to push
hello for date yourself about
coordinator session that so this is no
surprise if you're if you're a big Redis
person you are big customers and you may
be thinking who cares and why are you
showing this to me um but it turns out
this is actually a really nice model
especially for doing embarrassing
apparel imitations you have it for
nutrition and Vicki if the coordinator
which is whose job is to push things on
to want of expressions to evaluate along
to a queue and any of workers that are
basically just sitting there blocked
waiting for something to happen so in
this case as an example obsession two
expressions come in this means that the
two of the workers give jobs to do
they're good they're going to do
evaluations and then push their results
into it return q while this other worker
who didn't get a job is still just
waiting for things
so a really nice thing about this is
advised us this notion of communication
orthogonality which basically means that
the no 2 nodes in the network really
know about each other but they can still
communicate it's actually amazing so
it's a little bit formal than that and
it's it really means that two nodes in
the network know a minimal amount of
information to competing the problem is
that by doing this we're essentially
before centralizing data data movement
now in this case it wasn't as big a deal
because all the day is going back to the
coordinator but if you run into the case
where workers need to start talking to
each other that would mean we need new
new queues which means more use of
reddits and if there's a lot of a lot of
communication between the workers then
Redis essentially becomes the bottleneck
so I'm seeing knobs but not a lot of not
a lot of assertions is this a do people
already know about this or not too much
I guess that's not a well close question
for a poll and people on the internet I
don't know
um all right so all right so so again
with mpi you get really good performance
and you get these really nice for your
connections with a system can of it with
with a piece of software Laurentiis you
get communication or fog analogy which
essentially gives you a last icity so
let me put you back up one of the nice
things about this is because the the
coordinator in the workers aren't
directly tied I can add workers to to my
task queue at any time right so i can i
can add so i can i can scale up really
easily at the same time if I want to I
can start removing workers and then i
can if i add a little bit more
accounting the quarter coordinator can
detect when a task has been pushed
through and times out essentially in
which basically teresa by the text so
those are the two parts you need for
elasticity right unique of the fault
tolerance heart and they need to be able
to scale up and make use of available
resources as as
so again mpi is fats pure connections
Redis is elastic so the idea is can be
kind of can we kind of build a
communication that takes the best of
both these things off and Apollo's so an
elastic communication of framework that
also lets us do peer-to-peer connections
so I had this package of that the name
is actually called need area c is
assignment and people always ask how do
i turn out that and then they ask for
punished why did you pick that name it
was basically that i didn't want
anything i had to do at all with an
elephant the other thing was I was
originally thinking of I wanted
something that mcnabb slated this on you
a regeneration and I started by looking
it I was thinking about Hydra the
problem with that is it just seemed a
little like like early two thousand or
1990s member like we used to pick names
for things that were really like
aggressive like he know Kerberos and
servers which were you know the
three-headed dog
at garden he's so so so I went back and
looked at a look of Hydra and hydro
belongs to this phylum of organisms
called the military in the mid area and
I liked it also sounded like this
magical place where all your
distributing people bring up distributed
computing just kind of works so so
that's that is the mecca so so I'm just
going to show basically how it works so
I'm still going to use Redis or key
value database as a queue but we can
think of it as I'm going to second
submit I can submit a job and in this
case this is see a matrix multiply B
that is matrix multiply no are we have
this thing with putting % around things
now in this case this this computation
involves a so I'm going to actually tell
it to go to a oh sorry so this API so
this is so you can think of this as a
matrix a matrix B and we want to do a
matrix product C so it gets the job
realizes it doesn't have B and it also
we're still in the regime where the
workers don't
you know about each other so rather than
trying to figure out where workers he
puts in a job back into Redis that says
I basically says send a job to be and
the job is essentially send me your your
your B matrix the way this is actually
implemented is i'm using 0 and Q so
what's actually put out as the expert
out these the resource that's needed
along with the 0 mq m and so what
happens that is a submits the job and
then just wait to get to guarantee of
the actual burger so be consumed oops so
be consumes this and says all right I
need to send the date sends the data the
matrix multiply is performed and then
the thing that's return is of how two
choices either I can actually send the C
matrix back or i can say that or i can
tell i can even send a message today c
is now available out of a cluster
but AG yeah actually I've been busy bee
little rain yes yeah again that's
correct so right so I'm thinking about
matrix blocks here and this is actually
sufficient if I want to do a block wise
matrix multiply so this is kind of the
essential component and I'm actually I
am much more interested in kind of the
numerical linear algebra routines
because i think the MapReduce the
traditional MapReduce things are they're
done you know they we do them well
especially the job you know where he is
how do I know more about a review so so
the way so the way that I'm doing is
each one of these resources listens on a
reddit on a queue with its resource name
so a listens on a queue in Redis called
a so I kind of I kind of glossed over
that that's a good point them now what
that does is it not only lets me to
localize the computation but it lets me
localize clusters or I can kind of prove
things however will everyone I create a
new cues for for these workers to to
listen off but would a birth the
yes yes yes um alright so that was so
pictures are nice and they're good for
us to set for us to convince finger
things are working um but house
essentially used so how do you how do
you program is so this is where at work
there's actually a believable our code
so they're only two functions that you
need to know about if you want to if you
want to use this they're flush
essentially the idea is if you're doing
a poll you the art you're giving the
cluster an expression that it's going to
pull from where it's going to pull the
results of of the expression with a push
you're giving expression to consume and
then whatever that resources whatever
the result is going to stay out on the
cluster and you're going to handle two
so the arguments are where you want the
thing to where you want the expression
to be evaluated in terms of in terms of
the keys e to the resource location or
some other or some of the resource name
that you decided on the expression a
broadcast so should the expression go
out to all of the resources that are
serving or all of the the processes that
are serving a resource and then if
you're doing the push you made one
actually named native resource otherwise
we're just going to give it the globally
identifier so if I want to do the settle
of the geeks so the example that i just
showed what we're creating to see
customer to be done with this expression
so it's essentially saying go wherever
he is rubber be is take B and multiply
it by the thing that's returned by this
and the thing that's returned by this is
is is a is that a matrix so we're we're
we're pulling a on to be doing the
matrix multiply and it since this is a
push I can getting the resources i want
to call it C so this is a little bit
confusing because there's holes and
pushes does this make sense does this
make sense the way you showed with push
a will be right I showed with a first
yeah
oh yes you know what you're totally
right yes that's that's that's my
mistake that should you're right that
should be fetching table in which case I
should be pulling be yes yeah so we're
so confusing I did you can get it right
if you have a few percocets nobody and
one of them has a and B this video and
not by default which you what you could
do is you could tell the worker you
could yes yeah oh yes yep so a nice beer
a and B that is look up in this case it
will time out what you if you're if
you're in urging where you're worried
about machine is coming down then what
you would do is start serving blocks
redundant because that way if one of
them went down if one of the riba if one
of the machines went down with the
resource that you're interested in or
where the resources actually where the
computation is taking place then what
happens is that computation times out
the coordinator the coordinator
essentially sees that the computation is
find out into the Ray submit it though
if all the walks are being served or
done dling then then the computation can
still take place albeit one on different
machines
ah so
so
how do I protect you from calling itself
so write it so something so you're very
worried about like an infinite recursion
essentially i'm asking before they could
guess who called me for the golems are
going no i don't i bet i don't like so
yeah so that's that's a good point so
there there there is there's potential
for fault there yeah and without without
some kind of checkpointing for each one
of the each one of the operations on
further coordinator that's yeah that's
what that is tough to get around the
only thing is no that's yep that's right
the enough yet there's not an
appointment for the courting or so i
can't go down if it does go down tho
those resources still and those
resources still will just out on the
cluster so if there is a if there's a
record of the of the resources they're
still available if you were to restart
the coordinator is it
which mechanism like when you say so go
there to workers are putting from the
same videos on saying like Gayle read
which one gets which so it's with
Brennus it's it's it's ready ready
essential oh it's right yes yeah so yes
I'm one of them will get it only and
only one of them only one yeah so so if
you know about distributing including in
like the eighties this may look a lot
like tubal spaces and a lot of ways it
is and it does satisfy these four
essential these four essential
properties for Jenna generative
communication framework at David
furniture identified in a paper in 1985
for space uncoupling time uncoupling
distributed sharing and support for
continuation I'm actually going to go
through each one of those but the punch
line is that you can support a large
class of communication patterns step
that you can with mpi fun I'm not that
that you can't necessarily with with
with members who was a lot of the matter
new string works
um so these four properties the first
one is space and custom which basically
means that a resource can be used by any
member of the cluster so once i do a
push and I get and a handle is returned
that's a handle for that resource anyone
on the cluster can use it someone can be
told or more involved in expeditions the
time and coupling means that the
resource is there until it's actually
until it's explicitly removed this is
actually one of the places where I
needed a tow for a broadcast so so if I
actually want to remove all instances of
a resource on on a cluster I can just
say on scene remove see broadcast troops
oh that's going to go to anywhere that
there is a slug resource see being
served and over if it will remove it and
I'm doing a poll so nothing nothing is
being nothing's being kept out on the
cluster after the app after the result
on the distributed sharing
right so the practice is saying the data
can be shared across different our
sessions this isn't yes oh I already
said that well we can store resources or
definitely this is one of the things
that I just do kind of a multi multi man
MapReduce and if we want consistency we
actually do if that has a consistency
for data structures that actually has to
be implemented as a policy in other in
other words as a convention the
continuation passing that that's a
that's a little more of a technical term
but the the the big the big thing to
realize about that is it's basically
that you can you can have poles with
poles or pulls or pushes now this is
something that causes a lot of problem
or that originally cost a lot of
problems in our because our a single
thread right so so then right so then
there's the question how to actually
handle deadlocking and you want to see
how you would come you could cause it a
letter deadlock it's essentially doing a
saying go hey and go to be and try to
pull a back to or pay back to be because
our single threaded
and would he would be blocking waiting
for waiting for B and so this this would
not that this would not normally return
so too so to handle that we needed we
essentially need it our to be able to
work a little more like nodejs where we
need we need to be able to essentially
fork and kind of forget about a process
which didn't exist in our until version
3.1 and then we also needed to be able
to fork and then change the state of the
parent process so when I first ran into
this side was shaking like this and the
oxygen tennyson in python and it turns
out if you if you're nice to people in
our core and you present things that
they may think it worthwhile you can you
can get certain functionality so so the
first
the first a little bit of our service of
the first bit of functionality that
Simon added was its enhancement to the
BMC parallel function so for people at
our power programmers in our there's a
function called MC parallel and
essentially does it does a fork of the
process it executes San expression and
then and then you can read the result
back you can pull when you get a spurts
ready the problem with this is for a a
poll on a worker essentially I didn't
want to return anything and if I didn't
return anything within the old version
of MC parallel then I have these I have
pipes that essentially were not being
cleaned up so you get a kind of a
resource leak um so so now there's this
there's this new business new option
called attached and you can think of you
say detached equals true kind of a fork
and forget that the r-process does
whatever it needs to and you'll never
hear about it again this is exactly what
I needed for my poles on the worker side
because essentially the worker gets a
new expression it's going to fork and
then execute the expression the the fork
process has has 0 mq endpoint so if it
needs to if it needs to if it needs to
move things too
so when it needs to move things to
another worker or the courier it just
does that and it kills itself the other
the other bit of functionality is for
East pushes essentially needed to be
able to change the state of the parent
process of a worker based on a question
that's since since the workers since
after a push the worker has a new is
providing a new resource just forged are
forgetting isn't good enough you need to
fork and then update the state of the
parents so the way that we can do that
now is with the background package if
you're looking for if it's not on cran
it's not an artwork you have to give a
hour for Jeanette which is Simon's
package repository and basically the
idea is that you can give it a
you give it an expression execute and
then you can give it a call back the
callback is executed on the callback is
executed after the result of the
evaluation on the pair is rich on the
child has returned back to the parent so
for me with the worker I have a separate
environment where I'm keeping all the
resources that are being that are made
available to the cluster and basically
they call the callback now updates
updates that environment here's an
example if you want again it's on our
Forge diagram so the communication
framework is okay r is a disease of it
is fun but it's still very lovable and
whenever we're doing data exploration
state analyses we don't actually care
about doing things like moving data from
from machine
machine I don't I don't even like
writing that math introduced type things
myself I like to deal with really high
level data structures I'd like data
frames I'd like to be I like be the way
that we definitely query it into them
whether it's with our or or with the
pandas package so so one of the things
that I did was I follow their kind of
conventions now for doing distributed
data structures in our and I think one
of the best examples of this is in
society be our package from brian lewis
they have they have a couple of
conventions so basically the idea is
distributed data structure should look
as much like an analogous local data
structure as possible that means that
going if if if the local data structures
of course things like bracketing the
distributive things show Dashon beef it
should be a function for HMV a disk
operator local agency operator for the
distributive um the other thing is in
our yeah so any of the operations that
you're doing should stay out on the
cluster you should not be bringing data
into the coordinator doing work and then
pushing it back out but sometimes you
actually you need to move data onto the
coordinator so you can emerge the data
set up an open bracket closed bracket at
the end of an expression the nice thing
about this in our is that we're not
flying
we're not violating the convention so in
our if you have say a vector and you
index it so you v of 1 to 10 and then
you do an open bracket closed bracket it
actually returns you the same vectors if
you've said to be from 1 to 10 so we're
now we're not we're not really imposing
a new condition on on how we on how they
will distributed data structures the
other thing is you should again because
you always you should always be able to
bring the data back but they need to
maybe really do we should be able to
create an iterator to actually iterate
through different chunks of the data and
be able to handle what these wise as you
need to um so so to actually have a
couple of these data structures done now
the the distributive vector turns out to
be it's we think about what it's how
it's actually implemented are it's very
simple right it's basically a CRA the
nice thing about it is we can index it
with other with other vectors now
because one of the things I really
wanted to be able to do is index a
distributed vector with another
distributed vector this is actually
where a lot of a lot of my work but when
it so basically at this point I so right
now as it is right now you can do things
like you can create a stupid Decker and
I'm just filling it this is a relatively
small distributor it's only a thousand
values kind of using chunk sizes of 79
it's again each one of the blocks is a
vector of these random normals of size
70 value then here I'm going to undoing
a I'm sampling from one wavelength
distributed vector so that's sampling
from 1 to 1,000 I'm sampling 35 values
and I'm creating a block size of the
block size 14 so one of the really nice
things about this is you can start
mixing and matching block sizes if
you've done things with school a pack
you know that's not always that easy
it's also Loula it's it's and it's
tricky with most distribute linear alg
persistence and then what you can do is
I can actually fix one distributed
vector with another distributed vector
so all the data movement is handling all
and properly and I can check that this
works because I can i can check i can
check that this works by emerging DV on
to the local machine emerging I be on to
the local machine indexing local de with
local IV and then making them to make
sure that it's equal to this expression
that I had before of the merged oh so
that's basically how I've been testing
so so why did I spend so much time on
this on on the vectors so it turns out
anytime I want to do indexing or a lot
of logical expressions with with data
frames we're always pray protectors
right so let's what time you
and once I can new binary in fixed
operators like or and then I can start I
can start with indexing distributed data
frames so the block the block model for
disturbing data frame right now is that
I'm assuming that it's a relatively
small number of columns and I'm taking
blocks row wise the reason for that is I
kind of decided that is really why that
you actually don't want to do some
distributed into frame I guess people
don't like it they can write their own
versions but because I now have
distributed vectors working correctly I
can get I can get all this indexing
functionality first distribute data
I'm currently working on distributed
matrices this is actually the part that
I've the most excited though we did some
early tests with with this and again
because there's brokering mechanism for
many of the day of movement we don't
expect to be as fast as FBI and with mpi
all the data movement is is already
decided on upfront because we're doing
this brokering we expect a little bit of
the leg it turns out that it's actually
the benchmark showed for pretty small
examples that they're really comparable
so we don't think we're losing too much
up with with with the program ski the
other thing that we can do is because
these matrices are just our objects and
our knows how to do those how to
multiply sparse and dense matrices we
don't have to distinguish between a
dense distributed matrix and a sparse
distribute matrix which is also a big
deal so we can handle you get a lot of
these matrices that are clumping
especially if you're viewing with with
with social network data you get one or
two people that are connected to
everyone
people that are connected at No 1 and
and it can be it can be difficult
deciding if a sparse representation is
correct or deaf stuff representation for
something like this we don't actually
care all are all we really are doing the
sperm again because we're just we're
just moving our objects that we can
multiply and it's easy enough to
actually describe computations so if I
have a matrix oh so sorry the other
thing is the mayhaw a distributed vector
is represented by a vector of of
identify so just to be the matrix is
actually just represented by matrix of
the resources so if you can do a
strength basically the string product
via for the matrices these end up being
the computations that we did that need
to happen out on the course and that's
relatively easy
we have a kind of persistence model for
distributed data structures so right now
you can think of it as an inventory
database that you can do all kinds of
numerical things um vs model is actually
pretty easy because if any time a
resource is updated it's actually
it'sit's copy and then written to disk
then you actually have a transactional
model and it's not which is not that and
it's not that difficult to Temple that
I've started thinking about stuff with
string problems in particular mentorship
feedback problems which would be easy
enough to describe using the using using
the current infrastructure and then the
other thing is I kind of glossed over
this before but the cue scheme with
revis is is nice and it was really easy
to implement in fact I almost there was
almost nothing that's just listening on
cues the problem is that probably won't
scale to you know once to probably order
tens of thousands of cues in that case
you can actually need to go into a full
schedule of rather than the currency and
that's that that's something we would
need for if we wanted to really be able
to scale to really
permissions here are some references for
further information the I'm just
integrating the the DA synchronous
asynchronous functionality like this
week it should be done and we'll begin a
half or so d of it here's a location of
the background package you want to see
the code that's behind the stuff that I
talked about today it's on github I have
a newspaper on this and you can you know
me any questions that you have all right
so are there any questions yes you have
any sample code perhaps comparing world
the straight other work
in sorry she liked the work on sample is
that a world of parallel samples you
have a version of that implemented in
area that does sorry but which simplest
work out oh no I don't actually yes that
would be a good one especially since a
lot of the other work I do is actually
the phone text so that's another yes and
that would be a really nice application
for for sparse force parsers mix parson
fence matrices I don't that's a really
good idea though and I thought yes I'm
going to I'll definitely get on that the
matrix stuff is not is is a little less
further along it makes less further
along than the vectors and data frames
and I won't I'm probably won't get to it
for a couple of weeks but that's are
really nice that's a nice application
thanks yeah I'm division comedic
everything how does it just to read
sparse matrix so right so so Ian up are
so again so hey so a dense matrix is
essentially a vector that we index into
in two dimensions for a sparse matrix
you usually have their calls up you can
do other either column compressed or row
compressed where basically you say for
you give so broke impressively you give
a row number and earths are you give an
index work Row one for example Starks
and then we're wrote two starts and
between anything between those two
indexes up from one
anything from that first index up to up
to where r 0 2 starts would be columns
of the first of the first matrix another
easier way to think of it is basically
it's the coordinates of the nonzero
elements of the of a sparse matrix right
so most of number 0 there's no point in
me having we paid a big one of vector of
zeroes it's it's a it's a much more
efficient representation if I basically
give you the coordinates of the non zero
and then give you how give you the
coordinate in the actual value since it
is where'd it up with the value of the
non zero distributive department oh so
for the distributive park come if an
entire block is 0 then we can keep track
of that on the on the coordinator side
right so I could make it I can make it a
10 a because basically you know anything
that involves that block I don't I don't
even need to send out to the cluster I
know the results of that zero block and
x it by something else but you just or
some other information with this block
exist there which in a non-district way
well okay so so for the distributed
matrix the actual matrices that are
holding the data can be either sparse or
dense the coordinator doesn't even need
to know that they are because if I'm
doing something like the matrix or the
multiply that I showed at the beginning
what happens is I just pass either so se
this se one's dance one sparse and say
and exempt what I have basically i move
the sparse thing over the sparse matrix
over to where the dense matrix is and do
a matrix multiplying our already knows
how to do that mixed dense sparse matrix
multiply I don't like that yeah so it's
it's handling the actual representation
of the underlying data forming all the
coordinator really need to know is where
the resource is because we don't make
your mark yeah
are going to distribute it looks so so I
think ambitious sure okay you're copying
data around okay how do you kind of
stale data with ah yes so so for
the example that I showed in the
beginning the convention right now is
that once the expression is executed
this would be a temporary object in our
and it would just be garbage collected
unless unless I brought it over
explicitly now but i Kenned in which you
can do this Cheers yeah so your question
is basically what happens if you have
more than one be out here and I want to
update one of the bees so that has to be
handled by convention right I need to if
I'm going to update be I need to
actually do a broadcast and I so that
every single one of the bees it is
updated otherwise then i can run into
consistency issues so i guess the
solution is basically a hat
by convention or policy there's nothing
there's nothing in the low-level
distributed computer network that
precludes you from doing that so you
could run into cases where you don't
where you don't have parity with me just
being distributed objects but it's easy
but it's easy enough to get it together
but managing mattox operation in the GPU
is this compatible so on the GPU I think
so yeah so one thing yeah so on I guess
one thing to note is in this cuz this is
related to the representation is the
coordinator is only creating expressions
right um there's nothing in the
framework that dictates how this matrix
multiplication actually is going to
happen so if i compile our against like
the Intel math kernal library then on
that machine it's going to use the
mascara library so I think for a GPU
because our isn't isn't that as far as I
know it's not tightly integrated enough
with the arse not tightly integrated
left but that you get on GP behavior
with the matrix multiply but you could
change this so that rather than be you
know times this thing could be you know
it could be young GPU multiply a and
then pull it right so so you could
incorporate it in may it may be it may
require you to be one to change some of
the expression resource so one so each
queue identifies a resource on the
network that that the actual the actual
data associated with that resource can
be in more than one place on the cluster
like so so that so that's essentially
that redundancy that you get so if a
machine goes down and it has a resource
if it's served or done Emily and then
you can still you can still handle
computations that involved that resource
but everybody's busy these deals with a
number of resources can adjust that not
correct right yes
okay any other questions all right thank
you